[music]
Hi everyone. I'm very excited to be here
and uh glad to see there's still a lot
of people here even though it's been a
long and probably a bit hot day. Um so
the topic of today's session is actually
around world models versus task task
specific perception. And I think this is
actually a really interesting topic
because on the surface uh you know it
sounds very easy like a very simple
question but I think with the current
acceleration in physical AI there's
actually a lot of complexity and
actually lots of different schools of
thought in terms of how we need to
actually um progress in terms of
perception and capability in order to
accelerate uh the development of
physical AI and the deployment of
humanoid robots. And so there are
different uh ideas around general world
models, VA architectures as well as
highly specialized models. And the panel
we have today is actually a very diverse
panel that will actually I think
represent some of the different ways in
which people are actually approaching
this problem. So to start with, I'd
actually like to start with just a bit
more of a general question um and ask
the panelists to share a view on what
they believe perception for a robot
basically encompasses in terms of what
the robot should actually see and what
do you think is the biggest uh shortfall
or current challenge in terms of what
the robot's actually not seeing today.
Um so maybe I'll just start here.
>> I think the robot needs to see what it
needs to see. uh and that doesn't mean
that it has uh to have the same sensors
as the human and that is the biggest
difficulty is that the human is always
the developer of a system and needs to
understand what goes wrong because a lot
of development is debugging um yeah edge
cases h and yeah with deep learning of
course we have this neutrality to
sensors and also a very good um yeah
model to
uh look for the needle in the haststack.
So um that's my view.
>> Hi, my name is Inhy. I'm the CEO of
Ninetic Spatial. Let me just give a
little context to answer the question on
what robot seeds. We don't build robots.
We don't build the bodies nor the
brains. What we do build are the
foundation models to give you geospatial
awareness. Much like humans need a map.
Think of us as building a 3D
highfidelity map that is machine
readable for robots. autonomous vehicles
and also can navigate spaces in a safe
way, efficient way and in spaces where
GPS is denied. So you can imagine the
possibility of where that has value for
robotics. The piece that I think is
missing in data is is data. um meaning
unlike LLMs, you're going to need more
verticalized special data that often is
somewhat private and real data for
deployments. So,
>> um hi, I'm Hassan, CEO of X-ways. Um
also like yeah, first thanks for the
invitation. Super happy to be here uh in
front of all all of you guys. So, uh um
quick introduction about Xways. So at
X-rays we are building a foundational
layer for uh perception in a general
sense for mobile robotics more towards
like wheeled robots or drones. Um but
really what we build can adapt to any
kind of robots including humanoids and
what we have been focusing on for the
five pastures is uh mapping and
localization with 3D LAR sensors. So
that's just to give a bit of a
background and I would say that the for
us so in our perspective the one of the
biggest challenge we have right now is
making the models we are building um
more generalizable meaning that when you
have change sensor um like our sensor
sets uh being able to adapt to uh
different kind of sensor [snorts] noise
or scanning pattern or stuff like that.
And of course I I I join you on the on
the data availability and stuff like
that. But um hopefully with all the
progress we have on world models and
stuff, I think that we will have uh way
more data and having access also to edge
case data which is super exciting for
the future.
Okay, I'm Alex, CEO of flight. Um to
answer your question, perception it does
not exist in isolation. It's means to an
end and the end is actuation and action.
So robot needs to see whatever
it needs to see in order to trust the
environment and uh as light we measure
pixels. We we measure physics directly
not infrared from pixels at runtime. So
we share it a little bit although we are
not uh married to lidars or anything
else. Evolution didn't have lightars
available. No lasers
evolved.
Um so
what's most important in perception is
something that
doesn't fail you because the cost of
error is catastrophic many times. This
is not an hallucination. You can change
a word or two. If a robot fails and uh
crashes something or crashes the human
that's the end of the project. So safety
>> um I think that's very interesting in
terms of you know there's a couple of
answers here around well the robot needs
to see what it needs to see to go and
actually make the actions and the
decisions. So I guess brings us back to
the fact that there maybe isn't one
single view of what actually the robot
needs in order to be able to effectively
function. Um but I think right now in
terms of there's a lot of emphasis on
VAS and visual models. Um but I've
already heard a couple of things around
LAR and other sensors. So maybe I kind
of want to throw back to Hassan and
maybe then Alex um to talk about do you
think that there has been enough focus
on other forms of uh you know uh
basically different modalities uh
incorporated into robot systems today?
Um do you think that's something that's
going to be very important um in order
for robots to actually be able to see
essentially the information?
>> Um yeah super interesting question. So
first of all, I don't think it's it's
never enough, you know, like we still
need to push uh on on vision based um
models even though like the state of the
art today is is mesmerizing. I mean I've
been working on this field for the past
15 years and it it's just amazing the
pace of evolution but for sure there is
more room on u building foundational
models on uh LAR data 3D data and that's
what actually we are focusing on right
now at Xways. So yeah, pretty hard task
uh and have part of my team in the
audience and that's the the hard job
they they are working working on right
now. Um and also one thing I would would
like to add is maybe the next step is
also being able to have to build uh
foundational embeddings with joint uh
sensor modality modalities because you
have Alex talking about like safety and
I deeply believe that uh safety comes
from redundancy and being able to truly
fuse sensor modalities at this lower
level is is really the the next step and
super hard to do because even before
talking about models and and AI and
stuff. We always have been uh hearing
about like fusing light with cameras or
lightars with radars, cameras with
radars and that's a super hard task to
do at the lower level but super
interesting stuff to to work on.
>> Thanks. [clears throat] So I
categorically subscribe to um early
sensor fusion. Um in terms of sensors I
think there is not u there is a tax to
pay. So smarter sensors, smaller brain.
Smaller sensors, bigger brain. In fact,
humans have a very big 20% of our brain
is to process visual. Uh for mice, for
example, uh there is additional one that
processes whiskers
big portion because they they kind of
sense. So I think it's a trade-off. It's
also where you pay the tax. you either
pay the tax at at uh training or or you
pay the tax at uh inference. Uh so there
is no one good answer. Uh what I would
like to say is
my feeling is that we should not be
dogmatic about this sensor modality.
Physical AI needs uh to use all
available means to be safe and efficient
and fast and economical. So um really
hotly subscribe to multimodel fusion
measuring directly preventing these
little failures. Uh that's something
that will make robots real.
Yeah. At at Robo Vision we have thousand
robots in the field already for uh 10
years. Um so a base that has grown
steadily and what I hear not so often is
the business case. uh every situation
with a robot needs a business case and
the business case has a cycle time and a
cycle time creates dependencies on
sensor and on training stuff because if
you have to deploy over thousands of
situations you cannot go to Ohio to a
family business of four people and stay
there with two weeks with experts. So a
lot needs to be engineered in. So I
would say that whatever technique is a
good inspiration uh and becomes a
configuration to a business to be
deployed because all in all we all raise
money as tech startups. We need to get
that money to our investors with a
multiple and that means that uh apart
from the technical analysis we need to
do a lot of business case analysis and
this industry is of course extremely
young. There is a lot of billions that
go into humanoids, but if you look at
the business cases, it's not entirely
clear. You see them jumping and kung
fuing, but in the end, it needs to work
in a logistics plant. It needs to uh do
the payback for the one who paid the
money.
>> Can I add to that? I also think the
economics are changing a lot. So, I
think about what we're building at
Niantic Spatial as being cheaper,
better, faster. Um so when I think about
the cheaper it's uh the cost of of
cameras has come down quite a bit and we
can understand your standard
off-the-shelf iPhone or Android phone
camera as well as 360 camera. So the
ability to even scan a space has gotten
easier and faster. So we can do that uh
much quicker in minutes possibly hours
doing this whole station F as an
example. In the past, you would have
spent days. You would have had to use
really expensive equipment. Now, you can
do that in a few hundred dollars. The
last piece is really the use case.
Depending on if you're in an industrial
complex, are you doing cityscale
logistics delivery? Um, what we want to
do is really think about making sure
whatever your use case is that we're
efficient, you're getting better
optimization, and as Alex hit on safety.
At the end of the day, we're talking
these are non-deterministic spaces,
meaning spaces where you're going to
have humans or robots interact. And you
have to be able to have clarity around
um all of the all of the possibilities
of movement for not only the robot, but
also the human. So, you want to keep
both completely safe.
I feel like uh Ini you touched on a
really good point there which is
actually the fusion of different kinds
of information and uh to actually enable
the safety and actual and deployment of
robots. So it feels like even though the
topic is world models versus task task
specific perceptions, sorry this is such
a tongue twister. Um but it feels like
actually to some extent maybe these
models actually need to coexist and um I
know that you're working on a lot of
these uh spatial models and bringing
this together into world models so that
you actually have the location data and
be able to have the geospatial
awareness. Um, so I'm just curious uh
from your perspective if you can uh
provide a bit more insight about how you
see this maybe coming together in terms
of the interaction across different
types of models um and the full set of
capabilities.
>> In the large language models category,
you can have a generalized model um
because it's easier. Language is for
text, writing, speaking. As you get into
the category of physical AI, it I don't
think there's a single generalized
model. Um if anything it's going to be
more specialized vertical as well as
domain um horizontal rules. It'll also
be uh determined on the rules. As an
example, you can fly a drone in I'm
headquartered in San Francisco. We have
an office in London. You can fly a drone
in San Francisco. You cannot fly a drone
in Los Angeles downtown. There are
different rules by city, by location.
So, if you were to do an aerial uh
reconstruction that incorporates data
from the air plus the ground to do 3D
reconstructions, you're going to be
constrained by the rules of the city.
And every city is going to be different
around the world as an example. Another
example is if you're um deploying robots
in an airport versus I'm deploying
robots in an industrial factory or a oil
and gas refinery,
you're going to have machines, a lot of
physical equipment. Uh GPS is denied in
both places. Uh and the way you want to
operate in terms of the safety
protocols, the interactions and the
services are very very different. So
it's going to require uh unique data
sets that are provided by those
enterprises wanting to engage. And so
that's the way we think about it is
these specialized models but the
computation of space at a what we
consider a voxal meaning the volume and
what comprises a space is unique and
that can be generalized over time.
I would just add to that that it's a
configuration that suits a business case
and still a human team that has to
choose uh what is most uh appropriate
for a specific business case. I think
this is also an evolution of robotics.
So if we look 10 20 years ago, robotics
was uh pre-programmed right there's this
famous graph by I think someone in
someone at NVIDIA maybe Jensen. So
pre-programmed then specialist robots
and then specialist generalist. So I
think we are somewhere nearing the
specialist but this is not the end
right? This is a path. So with evolution
we will get someday to the robots that
will do everything equally well. Today
robots have bodies. Uh there are
projects right projects have budgets and
rather than trying to solve the whole
world uh it's easier to just concentrate
on one task and solve it.
I'd like to dive into that a deep a bit
more because um even though you know you
mentioned specialized to generalized I
feel like there's plenty of companies
out there that are focused on very much
generalized models and I think of world
models as being you know infrastructure
that we perceive that you know all
applications or deployments will sit on
top of. Um so I guess my question is do
you think that world model uh
infrastructure is a critical layer to
enable a lot of this deployment or do
you actually think that specialized
deployment um without the real emergence
of you know a mature world model will
come first and is that actually the
maybe more cost-effective or high ROI
approach towards deployment.
I I think u we can learn a lot on how
the LLM revolution took place and what
you see five years ago it was terribly
difficult to prune a model and to make
it more efficient just by especially
training it on a thing and Andre Karpati
said that the LLM was almost like a new
operating system and I think this
parallelism holds completely true for
robotics. Of course, everything was
specialized not so long ago, but
everyone in robotics fully realizes that
if you go to generalistic models, uh,
and you specially train them on specific
situations, you better start with a
generalistic model and then you go to
the specialized model and depending on
the speed and the capacity of specially
training it, um, you can then fit your
business case. And of course, you have
two focuses. If a company fully focus on
a world model, that's the mission of the
company and it's almost like the
provider of an operating system in the
old IT world. And then you have very
pragmatic companies that will have a
closer interface with the customers and
and solve that on top of it much like
the old IT world where applications come
on top of Windows uh for instance and I
think many in the audience here are
already using this LLM as their entropic
context or chat context as the new
operating system to manage their lives.
Uh nobody's like clicking the desktop
anymore.
Uh yes super interesting question. What
I would like to add um is um uh for
about like um simulation. So right now
like it's it's a common knowledge that
like simulation is a super tool to um to
make deployment faster because you can
like in theory test a lot beforehand
before going to the field. But actually
where you work really with simulation
you find out that it's [snorts]
like today they are like expert tools.
you know, you need like to staff people
uh very expert on on being able to build
this whole simulation infrastructure.
And what I what I foresee with these new
um world model and not only on you know
um let's say like camera modalities
because we have seen like um gion
splatting you know world model that can
output ganian splatting or like 3D 3D
data that's super interesting because or
or even like LAR data with um with the
Google deep mind uh um effort research
effort. So this is super interesting
because for me what I foresee is that
like this world model will allow us to
have like a plugandplay simulation tool
because you just going to give like an
image snapshot or light frame snapshot
and then they will be able to to
continue this and also generate edge
cases which are like super interesting
for for safety for you know these um you
know very rare use cases. Um so for me
it's like this part of the answer that
that is super interesting because for me
this will bridge the gap you know as
making the simulation as just like as
easy to use as an LLM you know like just
to prompt it prompt it and then anybody
can can use it and generate synthetic
data in yeah like uh volumes that are
incredibly high.
>> Okay. I was going to say I also think
there's an unlock when you make
technology more readily available. So
yesterday we announced um additional
capabilities for USDZ format. So we can
take a three uh D let's say Gausian
splat that you've scanned with your
phone or 360 camera. You can go into our
web browser which is scanners and
construct that format so that it is
deployable within your training policies
for a simulation to real deployment
where the polygons and mesh are aligned.
My view of that is we're now making it
at a costefficient level. You can start
to test it. If you're ready to break out
of the lab and the simulation world to
the real physical world, we're a good
starting point for that. I think more
technology that's available that's
readily available that people can start
to self-s serve for the developers of
robotics in different ways and
components will unlock more use cases.
So when we think today about uh world
model uh what comes to mind is a data
center is like a 100 kilo what of
compute at the moment you wait for a
while right so I claim that this should
not be the case right this is just today
what we do at light we kind of collapse
the divide between perception and and
world modeling
I think with time the gap will be gone
and this will be the world model will be
created in the moment of perception and
uh as a nature inspired example we can
uh look at the better for example if uh
you know 100 miles per hour or 160 km
per hour for Europe uh ball uh for
baseball right the batter should commit
to the swing
somewhere where the the ball is like
one/ird of the way um in only. So
actually the better runs a world model,
right? It's a very fast one. It's kind
of a reflex. It's indistinguishable from
perception. But this is a proof that
there is a world model because without
what is world model is predicting the
next state of the world given current
state history and the action. Right? So
uh that should converge.
>> I think we're of course here in France
Paris um and we had this schism between
the old um popes of AI let's say Joshua
Benju Yan Lea and Jeffrey Hinton and and
Yan Lai is the world model guy and he
strongly believes that uh of course uh
the current architecture is not good
enough to build this world model. I
think this also uh deserves some some
attention that we're still not there yet
maybe as a substrate to absorb all this
data. Um and I was personally preview of
uh I mean I started my career at the in
institute of neuroinformatics in 1999
and there we were um really like tapping
into cat brains with electrodes to see
how they processed uh visual data and I
think we still of of course hopefully
not with cat brains but uh I still will
not yet dare to understand how efficient
our own brain works and maybe this a
whole AI revolution can compound to let
us escape from the semicon paradigm in
order to go to more fu flexible
configurations of matter to absorb
reality in a much more efficient way.
I want to add uh about since you
mentioned brain. So there is this world
u well-known theory that uh actually
brain is a bag of tricks. So each trick
is a perception, right? You you learned
it, you you don't think about your
tricks, right? But if the baby doesn't
have the tricks, uh it takes the baby a
long time to learn. On top of it, there
is some reasoning and kind of abstract
world model running. I think this is
probably the architecture that should uh
prevail because with no hierarchy, there
is just too much uh inefficiency going
on.
So I think it's very interesting to hear
that actually we all believe that
fundamentally we need some form of this
world model to drive um the ability for
us to actually uh create anything useful
to make decisions um and be able to
deploy. Um but it feels like even though
we all believe that's the case, we're
still far from it. Um but there are a
lot of tools, techniques and things that
are being done to address it. Um so I
just want to throw and another question
which is um what do you see as the
potential bottleneck that you think
needs to happen to come the challenges?
Is it actually something in terms of the
architecture? Do you think it's a data
problem? Um maybe what's one thing that
you think over the next one or two years
um we should be focused on um thinking
about how to break through uh to that
kind of next level. Yeah, it's a
combination of both. Of course, you need
and the data and innovations in the
architecture of uh this AI to be able to
work much more efficiently with with
this conundrum of data. I mean, it's of
course much more data than the the whole
text of the of the worldwide web.
>> Any particular type of data that you
think is is missing today or need we
need more of?
Uh well the problem is 3D scanning um
that the sensors are still lacking the
innovations of the AI revolution. So if
you look at where it all started with
the Microsoft connect um it was pretty
spectacular for that time. We're talking
15 years ago and what we have right now
is not so much better in terms of 3D
stream. It's still I mean it's maybe
doubling the resolution but it's it's uh
it's real sense took over at some point
but it's it's it's kind of lagging the
whole GPU AI revolution. I think that's
that's an important thing.
>> I'm laughing because uh some of you
might not know Alex actually was on the
uh core engineering team that uh
supported connect. [laughter]
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. I mean it was my reference design.
I'm guilty. Sorry.
>> Really? [laughter]
>> Thanks for mentioning.
>> Can I have your signature afterwards?
[clears throat]
>> It sounds like they haven't made much
progress since your design.
>> But are you agreeing with me or not that
there is not so much progress in 3D
streaming data apart? Of course, we can
do a lot with AI with RGB, but that's
not a hardware innovation. That's an AI
innovation.
>> Yeah. when we started I think 20 years
ago started prime sense with the idea of
giving vision to machines right and the
problem is was that there was no compute
right we made quickly made the 3D sensor
and the worked with about 2,000 robotic
labs which looked like uh two people and
half a robot so nothing really was ready
uh therefore the biggest commercial
application of connect was uh in gaming.
So it actually connect wasn't connect
was a kind of idea early idea for
perception and then it found its way to
face ID actually interestingly [snorts]
I wanted to comment uh on kind of a
whole different uh uh different thing
but maybe I'll uh I'll yield and then
then I'll make a comment. Maybe adding
on both your comments, I uh physics of
everything is a very broad subject. It's
so different than my prior background
before this job was I was president
product technology for docysine. So
language, LLMs, understanding um AI and
data in a readable form and going deep
on a vertical like that is easier task
than what we're talking about. And so
even for us, we're going down a very
specific computer vision aspect which is
on vision modalities aka camera types
and data types um old form pre-existing
data versus new scan spaces uh and to
make sense of that space through depth.
Depth is one of the UNITA aspects that
we have really uh the best researchers
um thinking about because it's a
complicated element when you talk about
how robots enter spaces, move out of
spaces, um what fits where. These are
not things you just search on Google.
You don't go because it's got to
understand the physics of how things
move. And then you add other aspects,
other sensory aspects, auditory, touch,
feel, temperature. These are really
complicated things. So this we're just
at the beginning stages. And as Alex
said, the compute hasn't been available.
Now it's more available. I think the
modalities are going to increase. The
cost of sensors has come down. You can
now have more customized actuators for
robotics build. So I think a lot of
factors in the economics of these things
are changing and the tech is changing.
>> Just to refine the and continue the the
answer. So when there was no compute
nothing could help. Now now we have
compute right? Compute is get getting
better and better. Now when compute is
here officially uh I think the most
important is data. Um
actually architectures are are there
they will evolve as well but they're
kind of passible at this point. So data
and uh you know we all have the
cerebellum each one of us has it right
but there is one Ronaldo because uh kind
of there is a slightly better
architecture I would I would argue and
uh a lot more training right so a lot
more data a lot more actual observations
so we want Ronaldo robots going forward
>> maybe if I can add something so u I
would be the yeah the 3D guy uh I would
go like against what you said I Yeah,
hopefully like 3D sensors have evolved a
lot. I mean, maybe not that much on the
3D camera space which we're referring
to, but on LAR is just just insane like
seeing where we were 10 years ago and
where we are right now. So, um and yeah,
I mean
>> we can compare notes
>> and compare notes where we are.
>> Yeah. Um and and I would say to to
answer the the your question say is um
for me what the real challenge is of
course yeah as I mean as you said you
don't have like this whole uh bank of
free images where on which you can learn
for 3D data but I would say that the
challenge is not that much data because
you can like go plug a LAR on a car and
just drive a city and get like thousands
or even more hours of of data is more
how you you train your models, you know,
and like it's more the techniques, you
know, to self uh supervised training and
and not rely on just people annotating
uh point bypoint data. I think that's
that's the real challenge is and
leveraging all the stuff that have been
done on the other modalities to be able
to train faster these models on 3D data.
That's that's my answer to the the
challenge actually we are working on
right now.
>> All right. So, I'm going to close with
just one last question. Um, in the next
12 months, um, what's one thing that you
personally or your company is going to
be working on that you think will make a
difference, um, in terms of helping
robots see better,
>> coping with um, yeah, organic reality,
God-made products. A lot of challenges
[snorts] here have to do with households
industry logistics, but to really move a
robot head through a jungle of leaves
and grab a tomato and that's what we're
working on. That is something that we
really see working in 12 months with
Robo Vision.
So we announced yesterday sort of this
advancement around the policy training
from rim uh from simulation to real
deployments so that you can uh input
into NVIDIA's Isaac SIM uh as an
example.
What I see kind of a year from now too
is because of the way we're also
thinking about our models and being able
to put them at the edge on device in a
highly efficient way that'll unlock a
lot of opportunities. So I imagine um
there's constraints on compute on the
device. There's going to be constraints
on how much you want to spend and
mapping those areas. So I I think we're
I'm super excited about what we're
doing. So I welcome all of you to come
partner with us.
>> Yeah. on our side is including uh
temporal data into like the foundational
uh perception model we are building uh
on light on 3D data you know so it's not
just space but including also time and
that's something we um as x been
focusing on building simultaneous
localization and mapping uh software and
algorithm based on on lighter data and
we think that this is the key to bring
to bridge this gap you know in including
the the the time in like as a as a new
dimension to to the models.
>> We are now working with the leading
robotic to to enable next generation
robots. So maybe some of the robots will
be walking around. Uh in addition we are
providing the most complete uh physics
capture uh real time at capture time uh
set with geometry motion
um context color
u friction all other things and within
the uh next year we would we would we
are going to incorporate also internal
states of the robot as well as action
because uh in our view training robotics
training is nothing without action
because robots need to act on the world
and if they don't then they're not very
useful.
>> All right, thank you to our panelists
today um and hope you enjoyed the
session and we have obviously been
trading notes and there's already going
to be conversations coming out of this.
So hopefully um for everyone else who's
here feel free to come and uh chat more
about what we're working on this space.